вже 10 років аббас хусаїн props лікої
запала неясно то зубні біль його
кабінету розтушовані швейцарською
вміститися
зазвучати пацієнти розплачуються у
franck oliver нещодавно можете брат та
альтернативний варіант у нас можна ось
це біткойном це віртуальна валюта ми
спочив і прямота і рік тому заїхав словами
і поки що в биткоинах платила лиша
кілька пацієнтів все
зайти сфери сухий ведений за дикою
малини та чому зростання шива ньютонівським
подарунком тепер мені сто прогноз такий
великий прибуток їм про биткоинах мишкольце
може покажу 100 ват та цифрову валюту
для сплати комунальних послуг на суму
до 200 франків
ще мало процес знаю а лазаро лом я не
проти bitcoin або тканину з розряду
штучного інтелекту роботів cc та вірус
боязкою і я ланцюга три щогли допустивши до
кліпарт а ви ще думаєте я поважаю щець і
складний ринок на мою думку йому бракують
разу зростати дуже облич місця борг і міллер
правда перед воріт відсох накрити повіяв і
ну вин хоче при обід і фінансів і
технологічної компанії ще показником
місцю і відкриті для нових ідей з
україною для біткойнів спекулятивну
валюти занести курсом обміну
по вникав його не з правді і аличу і але
ми відриваємо а біткоїни ми можемо у мене
ти їх на швейцарський франк і для тіла
саме біржа і цілий би з піччю на світ
був навчальних витрат за гелька наносекунду
ще бутрим цієї доступ до біткойне
потрібно ще правда їхати і дотер х в
кар'єр не кофешоп аль стоїть один з
небагатих автомотив для біткойнів
швейцарії купувати та вставляє франки
шпалери брешу а вранці піти по перший чек якщо
сканування можна викрасти стіл у цій
для сплати цифрової валюти на приклад
рахунок зарплати ти тут за кого алі
биткойни миє і багато інших поривах
показник у гаю будь cool in і по три
бінбанк
ти можна труби то я хочу промені це дуже
економною квіткою так можна тут не ось
і мікроплатежі ще таким чином
відрубати можна бачити при 1 тис їжу
глобальної економіки вроздріб ми світимо
наразі опціях трансакцій з біткойном і
зал h а ця вечеря ейське
червоним статус поливаєте відлік ситуація
на за баром змініть